attention attention vous nous écoutez
deux par deux couples magnifique unis
par l'amour réunis par le mariage et
nous vous disons bravo bravo mais
attention si l'un des deux veut tout à
coup se séparer de l'eau faire commander
sa petite valise
il doit au moins sacrifier à la
politesse du coeur par exemple on ne
doit pas annoncer la chose comme ceci
une petite devinette qui est ce qu'il ya
deux jambes 1 et 5 enfants qui va se
retrouver sur le carreau si toi non
ça ça n'est pas bien il faut prendre des
formes c'est la moindre des choses nous
déconseillons franchement les raccourcis
du genre ou chérie tu sais pas j'ai pas
un bide et ne veut pas être lue par un
pass non non non ça n'est pas
d'hypocrisie non plus pas de numéro dans
ce style tu sais la grande asperge la
cie la blonde vulgate avec ce n'est
énorme
ouais la grande idiote et ben je pars
avec elle mais je peux te dire que ça
m'amuse pas un dit les choses avec
simplicité n'attendez pas de saisir la
balle au bond
si votre mari vous dis qu'est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui simone ne vous jetez
pas sur l'occasion pour répondre c'est
pas s'ils ont divorcé
rappelons nous par ailleurs que l'amour
n'est pas un jeu de hasard
il est mal élevé de faire ceci attention
les yeux pis le jeu reste fesses je m'en
vais à bâle ville on recommence au fait
ce manque de bol c'est lui ginette et
sans rancune
non ça n'est pas bien de même si vous
partez très bien apporter mais en
douceur sans commentaire c'est vrai
abstenez vous des critiques en plus ne
dit pas quoi tu es la vie devant toi
t'as 56 sentais pas marrante mais t'es
gentil sts dans les 400 francs par mois
et tu pleures niche elle mandy moore
sachez dire les choses comme elles sont
avec coeur avec générosité dit ceci ça
ne va pas le sien parlons réfléchissons
ouvrons nos lucien mais ne dit pas mal
honnêtement écoute ses parents nous une
vingtaine d'années à part ça on y verra
plus clair d'accord il n'est pas ça que
d'être simple ils vont pourtant mieux
dire ce que l'on a dit plutôt que de le
chanter par exemple pour faire
comprendre la situation à l'autre avec
un mauvais goût dans le genre cet odieux
c'est odieux c'est infect mieux vous
dire carrément c'est la fin mood cdu
c'est dur mais c'est moins dur que
d'entendre dans le genre sadomasochistes
c'est que tu me plais tout comme sa
dette à grosse bouche avec tes grosses
mahdi salve h ce qui me tue 1
fous l'camp fous l'camp jetés dans les
pôles et des victoires des corps enfin
le grand jour sera d'arriver le grand
jour du départ soit iemu soyez
inoubliable partait avec élégance dit
par exemple au revoir et peut-être à
demain marie madeleine
mais ne vis tu marques tu appelles un
petit bout ma grande tu es d apporter
mes valises jusqu'au taxi enfin le temps
se chargera peut-être de remplacer
l'amour par la différence alors ne
bousculez pas la chose je ne dit pas en
partant aller voir chez madame et merci
pour tous la cuisine et couture les
enfants c'était du tonnerre au revoir